Ali Ali Dawa definitely is dreaming
about you. Answering his DMs 100%
confirms he likes you. Ali, is this
true? Do you have a little crush on me?
So hayas. Okay. So you can see she's
always you know when someone you know in
my country they like they say half of a
joke it's it is real. So you're making
these jokes where you keep talking about
being married to me, being in love with
me, um sexual innuendos. Like I'm I'm
just genuinely saying sister with all
due respect please I I I I I have no
kind of attract
like please. Yeah. You don't know what
what what you're dealing with. If you
saw my wife your your jaw might drop.
Please you don't know what you're
dealing with. Please. Yeah. And with all
that fake eyelashes makeup. Wai you make
it worse for yourself. There's
impossibility. Please. And please don't
I with all due respect please. In your
dreams. In your dreams please. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Like I said before I not
take you a second third four.
Dear brothers and sisters, as we watch
what is unfolding today in we have to
understand that opposition is counting
on us to lose attention, to become
fatigued, and to move on with the new
cycle. And just as we can't allow them
to dictate our attention, we also can't
allow them to dictate the pace of our
solidarity. And part of that solidarity
is going to be there to rebuild Gaza
short-term, long term. I am proud to
give my support, my word of support to
trusted brothers and sisters in the
United Kingdom that have started a walk,
that have started an endowment to make
sure inshallah that we're there for the
long run. It's going to be long term and
we will not forget our cause and we will
not forget the cause of and we will not
forget our brothers and sisters in
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are inah to another
reaction video. This is going to be a
bit spicy and it's going to be
interesting inshallah and you're going
to see the reality of the western hijabi
woman where they are heading today. Not
all of course not at all. This this this
woman is an anomaly. I've been doing
that for 13 years. I've never come
across a woman that I may have disagreed
with. Dina Tokyo um rest whatever it is
you know I've done videos towards both
men and women Muslim men and women
advising them. Alhamdulillah. I have
never come across a woman who literally
gives sexual innuendos to a married man.
I'm I'm a married man. Alhamdulillah.
I'm just amazed that not only does this
woman insult indirectly my wife. If you
have a personal problem, that's that's
fine. Alhamdulillah. It's not an issue.
But she actually makes sexual innuendos
with a married man myself. I don't know
if she's married. I mean, if I was a
husband, oh boy. I I think this alone,
and I'm not I I don't want to ruin her
family. I I highly doubt she's married.
I highly doubt she's married. This could
even cause divorce. I mean, you're
speaking to another man and saying that
and this, by the way, this is if you're
under 18, please don't watch this.
That's why I put that disclaimer. Just
quickly just dissect the sexual stuff
that she came and then we're going to go
to her hadith rejecting um like you
cannot make this up, guys. Back in the
days, people like Imam Bkari, people
would travel distances. They would go
through hell on earth to narrate a Sah
hadith. And now we've got a sister. And
by the way, I do not want to attack her
natural look cuz I can't. Nobody can see
it. Not that I want to see it. your
eyelashes. Your eyebrows are not your
eyebrows. There's no way your eyebrow is
that thin. I don't even know your eye
color is your eye color. I don't know if
your eyelashes are real. Yeah. Maybe if
you blink a bit more too much, you will
fly. Your your lips are inflated. Yes.
Okay. That there's no way that's your
lips. You've got seven layers of makeup.
Yes. Okay. My wife was going through
your social media. There is not a single
place that you have we haven't seen of
you not wearing makeup. You are so fake
aesthetic like outside. Do you get it?
So I'm judging what is fake. The mask
that you have, not your natural because
Allah's creation is alhamdulillah. We
don't ever dis like I would never say to
Allah's creation this is ugly or
whatever. I'm not saying that cuz I want
to be very careful. I'm talking about
what you have. And the funny thing is
that you are so insecure and infuriate
about your look that you have to put
layers and layers of makeup, fake lips,
fake fake eyelashes, fake eyebrow and
subhan Allah, everything looks so fake
that you carry that to your religion by
rejecting hadith because you have an
insecurity there as well. Not just by
your looks. Yes. Not just by your looks
and spending hours and hours. If only
you just spend those hours point the
fake lip fillers and the eyelashes and
the eyebrows and whatever it is. If only
you just spend some time studying your
religion, the science of hadith, you
would not be rejecting hadith because
and I'm not saying you anyone that
rejects hadith is a kafir is a fivestar
grade a kafir. She claims she doesn't
reject all hadith some no problem. I'm
just saying some people in general
anyone that rejects hadith you're not a
Muslim. Now let's go to these innuendos
she made before we go to the actual
video. So this is the one because I
triggered her when I spoke about these
you know her fake looks. Yeah. I'm not
talking about her natural state. I'm
talking about what is unnatural. I mean
I don't want to envision um you know cuz
you going to completely defeat you with
makeup completely different without
makeup. So let's go through inshallah
these are the messages that she sent to
a married man which is myself. Let's go
through ourel inshallah. So the first
one somebody is commenting look just
bearing bear this in mind guys. She is
as far as I know she's someone in her
maybe early or late 30s. That's what she
looks like and this is the messages her
followers are sending. There's so much
sexual tension between you guys.
So I'm messaging her nia and just
telling her for example that you know
stop being fake with a lipstick et study
your religion etc. So this is a comeback
at me. Yeah. Somebody's commenting.
Imagine this. This I'm I'm a married I'm
a married man. Ah. Okay. There's so much
sexual tension between you guys. It's
tough for she goes. Haha. For real. Like
how the f did this happen? I was just
chilling in my fish stocking minding my
own business.
Okay. Let's go to the next one.
This one.
Okay. So, here obviously we blurred out
and you can see in her videos. Okay.
She's she wears she's literally the
hadith that says you are dressed but
naked. Tight clothing, fake lipstick,
fake eyelashes, fake eyebrows, seven
layers of makeup. Subhan Allah. I hope
you guys enjoy the video guys. But
before that, please download the Salah
Pro app. Brothers and sisters, we are a
charity. All of our services on the app
is for free. Free kibl finder, no ads,
free salah reminders, encourages you to
pray, tells you salah times. You can
book a salah instructor, a Quran
instructor. You can order a guided
prayer map for absolutely free if you
want to learn how to pray salah. Videos
on how to pray salah, salah hubs, and
many, many more brothers and sisters. We
are not an app that shares your
information with third parties. All of
our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah. And enjoy,
guys. Let's go back to the video.
Yes. And she's there talking about men
watching pornography, which she's 100%
right about men. Muslim men don't watch
pornography. But it's a bit hypocritical
because pornography is something that is
this is not real life. It's a warped
idea of what reality is. You're having a
go at them. But you are the same breath.
You are a that's not you. What you have
on is not you. I bet you any money. If
you took all of that out,
some brother who's looking to get
married, I'm not cing look might come
and say I was the you are you look
completely different. So you are having
a go at them do not watch pornography.
It's a false idea of reality but you are
the same person. You you're showing
yourself and you're not real. Let's go.
Okay, this one she goes, "Imagine Ali
DMs me and I'm on these days where I'm
afraid to go grocery shopping cuz I
could possibly fall in love with certain
vegetables."
What is she What are we talking
vegetables? I mean, you can see what
she's trying to say. Cucumbers or jeans.
Do you guys see where what she's talking
about? A male's private parts or certain
cucumbers that resemble. She's saying
she'll fall in love. I am wall. I'm a
man. Hay is for both men and women. Of
course, it's woman, you know, there's a
bit more more expectation in that side,
you know, cuz a woman, Allah has created
a um, you know, in a specific way.
Alhamdulillah, I feel shy as a man
reading this and I'm thinking this is a
hijabi and you think modesty is wearing
a this, by the way, this is not a hijab.
With all due respect, you have a
headscarf on your head and you're
wearing tight clothing. Okay, with all
due respect and this is you call hijab,
this is what you're teaching about these
to to these sisters. Subhan Allah. Subh
you you you don't basic and then she
goes and I miraculously fall in love
with Ali and we get married. I just want
to ask a simple question. None of my
messages that I sent her giving an
obviously cussing a fake look etc
whatever it is for that matter
did I ever insinuate anything about oh
you're in love with me you're this I
don't even talk that's not even mine
because I'll be honest my witness I
don't mean to disrespect you sister like
I'm intellectually just want to deal
with you in also talk about your
fakeness because that's hypocritical.
Yeah.
of the caba and I genuinely don't mean
this in in I'm not trying to insult you.
You are maybe the most unattractive
woman I've seen. Like person it's
subjective. Subjective.
Wahi. Wahi. I would wall you look so you
look robotic. Like you look like you
know those robots. Even the way you talk
it's very like it's like a very weird
way of you talking. Wahi I swear upon
the rub of the cabba.
>> I'm just I'm just being honest. You
can't you cannot be the dust underneath
my wife's feet. Like I genuinely there's
night and day. There's night and day
difference. Yeah. So, you're here
talking about imagine I fall in love
with Ali. Why you keep talking about
being in love with me and being married
to me and these sexual innuendos and
there's a sexual tension between us. Why
do you talk like that? I mean, I don't
know which man is going to wash this and
marry you. I There's no way you're
married. How are you talking like this
to a married man? Man, how well there's
no way you're married. There's no way. I
don't think there's a husband for me to
do that to. and I get married and I
accuse him of cheating on me and think
we had a another woman in the house
because my eyeliner gets empty with so
she thinks that I put eyeliner which is
basically it's a sunnah of co and by the
way I don't not that anything wrong with
it I don't put eyeliner anywhere this is
how my eyes are naturally yes and I'll
take that as a as a compliment again
you're complimenting another man that's
married please sister I would not make
you my second third or fourth wife
concubine I would not even accept his
concubine then without due respect
You are the if you was the last woman on
earth, I'll be celibate for the rest of
my life with all due respect. Okay, here
she goes. Nothing. Just chilling in my
fish stockings talking about sexual
stuff with me. She's admitted it
basically. Yeah. And somebody goes,
"We are with you. F him." Talking about
me. And she goes, "I love my followers.
They are like me. I agree with you. They
are just like you." Vulgar. I I couldn't
agree with you more, Ali. I know. And
this is where um apparently a message is
saying please carry on going cuz I was
you're making this you're just burying
dig your own grave. I said please keep
going please. She goes Ali I know your
wife never said this to you. Just just
think guys what kind of a perverted mind
this is a woman apparently Muslim in
hijab talking in this manner. It shocks
you. Hah sister work in the inner hay
first. Please sister work on that before
you talk about and your your outer hijab
is not is mashup let alone the inner
one. So girl, no. So she goes, "Girl,
it's the it's it's the time you roast
these brothers on real so Ali Dawa sees
them. I'm sure he'll be obsessed with
you and will stalk your video videos
from several accounts. Give him content
to talk about. It's it's a nice surprise
video. Ali Ali Dawa definitely is
dreaming about you answering his DMs.
100% confirms he likes you. Ali, is this
true? Do you have a little crush on me?"
So Hayalas. Okay. So you can see she's
always, you know, when someone, you
know, in my country they like they say
half of a joke it's it is real. So
you're making these jokes but you keep
talking about being married to me, being
in love with me, um sexual innuendos
like I'm just genuinely saying, sister,
with all due respect, please I I I I
have no kind of attract
like please. Yeah, you don't know what
what what you're dealing with. If you
saw my wife, you're your jaw, my drop,
please. You don't know what you're
dealing with, please. Yeah. And with all
that fake eyelashes, makeup wall, you
make it worse for yourself. There's
impossibility. Please and please don't I
with all due respect, please. In your
dreams, in your dreams, please. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Like I said before, I want
to not take you a second, third, five,
let alone a conquer. I would be like,
never. Okay. Then she goes, "Thank you.
Yes, I look look you I go, look, I said
you hurt me bad now. That was a
fantastic comeback. And did you say you
don't wear makeup?" I said, "You are
makeup." Then she goes, "Thank you."
She's sending flowers, rose to me. Yeah.
Okay. I don't know. I don't know what
kind of perverted mind she's got here.
Yes, I can come. Unlike your alleged
wife.
This woman is talking about sexual
stuff. I can come.
Allah has created makeup for us women.
The question is why do you wear it? I
don't understand. You're speaking to a
married man and saying I can come. Who
talks like that guys? Please. This is
really perverted. We think perversion is
with men. I mean people accuses us oh
man you're a walkie-talkie talking
pervert you're actual hey you're a
plastic jabi you're not real you're
you're a pervert like I've never seen a
Muslim woman in 13 years should I be
honest with you maybe in Jah before I
came to Islam you will come across girls
that talk in these kind of ways I've
never seen a Muslim woman
so yeah that's it now let's go to her
videos yes because let's go to some of
her videos let's see what she has to um
offer us and Before that and after we
are going to inshallah see a real sister
hijab who's not insecure who doesn't
have fake eyelashes makeup lip fillers
etc who follows Islam and I'm not saying
I don't know much of the sister I just
came across her but let's watch one of
them in so um let's watch her video
first and then we'll react to the other
one was not 40 she was 25 they say they
hate women over 30 because they find
them old and unattractive that's why
they marry the 20 year olds get them
pregnant and then they hate them because
they find them fat and unattractive.
>> I I'll be honest with you, it just seems
like there's a deep insecurity. I think
maybe she's in her late 30s and nobody's
married her and usually sadly with some
women when they, you know, reach that
they feel like, you know, unwanted. And
yes, men do want a woman that's younger,
more fertile, more beautiful in a young
age. There's absolutely nothing wrong
with that. Why is that a issue with you?
The reason you're saying that is maybe
you're in your late 30s, you look like
that. And maybe that's the reason why
and how you I use the argument that
she's 40 but authentic reports shows
that she's actually 25. But hold on a
second. You're a hadith rejector. How do
you make this comment about she's 40 or
25? How do you get the information? It's
in the Quran. Oh yeah, it's not. We'll
come to that. Anyways, let's let's move
on to the next one.
>> In the past is not an argument to defend
your prophet. So was burying people
alive. So was trading women on slave
markets. When Islam came, the prophet
prohibited all these things for the
Sahaba. None of the Sahaba were allowed
to marry a child. You can ask any
scholar you want. They will approve this
information. No Sahaba was married to a
child. And now, do you think the prophet
did it? Something which was clearly
prohibited in Islam?
Of course not. Some perverts waited
until the prophet has passed away and
then they came up with
with some books trying to make things
halal again. Use your brain.
>> Okay. So, as you can see, can you
imagine? Like, subhan Allah, she's so
insecure within her own skin that she
has to put seven layers of makeup, fake
eyebrows, fake eyelashes, lip fillers.
Yes. Do you think that looks attractive?
That's what I feel sick when I see that.
But she carries that onto a religion.
Why? Because there's a hadith that she
finds troubling. She doesn't understand
it. And instead of wall, sister, if you
spend 10% of the time putting makeup, I
don't know how long it takes you to put
all that fake stuff. It's like a mask.
It's like literally getting another
mask. That's not you. There is no way if
you was with no makeup, they'll look at
you and that picture they'll say, so
this is two different people. Wall, if
you just spent 10% of that time doing
some study on science of hadith, you
would have understand that, oh, it makes
sense. But because of you don't, because
you don't, you are insecure. Now, let's
go to a sister who doesn't look fake.
There's no fake, none of all that. Who's
not insecure about religion? Look how
she answers it. And look at the
difference. I've spoken to non-Muslims
about the marriage, the prophet's
marriage to Aisha. wall after I've
spoken they go that makes sense it makes
sense but an insecure hijabi fake jabi
plastic jabi what does she do oh no
that's troubling for me okay are you
going to reject the ay in the Quran
where Allah talks about and the uh the
period for a woman who's hasn't menrated
if we take that at face value we take
hadith we don't take the Quran only
because why cuz it's very clear there's
evidences clear evidences hadith
literatur it's been there for years okay
if you just don't take that are you
going to reject the Quran now because
it's talking about people vesting else
girls that don't mention it. There's an
answer for it, but using your argument.
So, are you going to say now the Quran
says, "Are you going to reject the
hadith now?" I mean, the Quran now
you're going to say, "Oh, oh, that's too
much. Oh, is that perverted as well?"
Because of your lack of understanding
because you're an ignoramist. Look at
how this sister understands it.
>> Old girl, how can you call Islam the
perfect religion when it children were
being married to a grown man? First of
all, judging a 7th century marriage by
using 21st century standards is totally
unfair because at that time it was
common across many civilizations for
girls to marry as soon as they reached
puberty. And according to Jewish law at
that time, girls could be promised for
marriage from age three and married
after reaching puberty. and even in
Christian uh Europe. King uh Richard II
of England married a six-year-old girl
named Isabella of Valois in the year of
1396.
So why do you accuse Islam for this when
it was normal in many other cultures at
that time also? uh children grew and
matured differently at that time because
they lived naturally with healthy food,
clean environment and no artificial
hormones like a 9-year-old girl on those
days was not like a 9 yearear-old today.
And if
>> there you go look look her that sister
dressed modestly. No fake uh um lens,
no fake eyebrows, no fake eyelashes, no
fake lip fillers, not 7 kilos of makeup.
Dress modestly. And guess what? You see
that resembling? She's authentic to her
religion. She has to come and say, "Oh,
no, that doesn't make sense." And one
thing I'm just trying to understand with
this this this other sister, why does
she talk in that way like a robot? Like
like she looks like a robot. And she,
Subhan Allah, I I find her very weird,
but she's very creepy. But anyways,
let's carry on.
>> When I hear people say that there are
going to be orgies in Jenna with angels,
okay, let's go back to the beginning.
You can see a human beings natural
futra. When you look at very young
people, when we look at young people who
are interested in the opposite gender,
for example, high school kids, everyone
has a crush on one person. This is
natural futra, Adam and Eve. These
thoughts you have of orgies, threesomes,
foursomes, blah blah. This is because
you watch corn. This is because you
watch the haram that Allah tells you not
to watch. That's why you mess up your
natural futra and that's why you think
something satanic will be going on in
Jenna like
well one second. You're talking about
your natural disposition being
corrupted. Okay. And she's right. But
when it comes to watching pornography
etc. It's 100% unacceptable. No one I
don't know who believes that you're
going to have um you're going to have
for lanes by the way you are. Yeah
you're sorry to dislike that as well.
You know, if Allah mentioned in the
Quran, oh, let me guess. That's not in
the Quran. Okay, that's fine. Oh, oh,
no, she doesn't like it. Sister Jam
doesn't like it. Okay, we're going to
make the Quran. How do you like Sister
J? Please, man. Please relax yourself.
Okay. Okay. So, but then you are the
same person. Your natural face. Look
what you've done to your face. Your
natural face. You've put all this stuff.
You are as fake as them and the
expectations. You are the standard
beauty sick. Go read that book, Beauty
Sick. You have sickness of beauty. Look
at what you've done to your face. Do you
think you look normal? You are as bad as
them of the expectations and you push on
people and you're talking about being
authentic and don't watch this and these
are all fantasies. Look at your face.
Look in the mirror. Do you look in the
mirror, please? For the for the love of
God.
>> I respect that. But you have to respect
that some other people think that some
things in these books are questionable
because as Muslims, the only book which
is not questionable is the Quran.
Everything else is written by human
beings. And if you believe that no imam
ever gave fatwa for money or politics,
then you are pretty naive,
>> bro. She gives me the creeps, bro. Why
does she do that? She gives me the
creep.
Why do you talk like that? I You give me
the creeps. Like, I want to ask you a
simple question. Okay, if that is the
case, okay, you reject Hadith, but
hadith came to us. It's like a woman
giving birth mother to two children. You
You take one child and reject the other
one. They came from the same source.
This one shows how ignorant you are.
Look, just listen. Go stick to hijab
tutorials. Stick to makeup tutorials.
Stick to flip fillers and how you can
have a fake eyelash. How to look fake.
Do a how to look fake tutorial. Who are
you to talk about this tradition that's
been going on for thousands of years?
Like wall, you're an absolute
ignoramist. The reason I'm doing this
video is because of this issue, not
that. Okay, you have no hay. You're fake
inside and out. Not only that, the Quran
you accept the hadith came from the same
source. No, we reject. Okay, if that's
the case, how do you pray salah? How
many times do you pray salah day? How do
you do?
How do you do Hajj? How do you get
married? How do you know which way to
face the How do you know? Please,
please, please tell us enlighten us. In
one video, she goes basically which
which I'll play a minute ago. She goes,
"Oh, how do you do or do?" Oh, the pagan
Arabs used to do it. The pagan Arabs.
Can you imagine? The mushiks know how to
do, but Allahh didn't reveal that. Like,
can you imagine? She learns it from the
pagan Arabs. Okay. And this goes back to
what, guys? Inferiority complex. You see
a common pattern with this Quran
rejectors, which is what? The stoning to
death. No, never happened. Promise
marriage to Aisha. Uh-uh. Anything
that's troubling to them, you know why?
because they have been affected by
liberalism. Oh my gosh, I can't deal
with that reality. Instead of educating
myself like the sister done, instead of
educating myself, I'm going to reject
the hadith literature and I'm an
ignoramis, absolute ignoramis that knows
nothing. So imagine 1,400 years people
have been praying five times a day. It's
a mass conspiracy. It's been made up. So
how how do you know how to pray? So how
do you know how to pray salah? Please
can you tell me? How many know how do
you know the units? What to do? Please
tell me. I want to know. Yes. Do you do?
Yes. Maybe you don't. That's why that
makeup is always, you know, there. Maybe
you don't. How do you know how to do?
How do you know this stuff? How do you
know abrogation? How do you know the
alcohol verses were abrogated? How do
you know? Cuz you need
all of these people that look they took
from they were hadith acceptance. They
accept hadith abrogation of alcohol. How
do you know it was you can still come to
salah drunk? How do you know it's
abregated? How do you know this stuff?
Please tell me. Okay. Please tell us.
And not only that, let's go to a Quran
verse in the in surah surah nah verse
44. Yes. We send them with clear proofs
and the divine book. So it's talking
about the Quran divine book. And we have
sent down to you, oh prophet, the
reminder so that you might explain to
people what has been revealed for them
and perhaps they will reflect. Well,
hold on a second. This is a knock out
blow. We sent to them with clear proofs
and divine books and we have sent down
to you oh prophet the reminder and so
that you may explain it to them. So how
is the measure of Allah explaining? Can
you explain that to me please? What is
this explain? What is this reminder? The
okay the explain. What is it? What's
what is that? Can you please tell me
how? Because Allah's make distinguish
between the Quran. Yes. Divine books and
also the explanation. What is the
explanation? Can you tell me now? Tell
me. Please tell me what's the
explanation. You rejected hadith. Okay.
How? How? What is it? What is it? Can
you please tell me? You have no answer.
You cannot explain this. You're just an
inferior. You're someone that has
insecurities. We can already see that
with the makeup and stuff like we can
see there deep insecurities. But don't
reflect that back onto our religion. At
least be fake with your body and your
makeup and your eyelashes and your lips.
Don't bring that fakeness to the
religion and try to distort it. Yes.
Okay. So, let's go back to the videos.
Inshallah.
>> Are prophets. There are people who claim
to be Mai. There are people who claim to
see Allah in their dream. How do I know
that your imams are not some crazy guys
who had some wild dreams? Imam Baba
said, "This is what the prophet's wife
said."
>> You know what's really interesting? She
sent me a voice note once I showed her
the thumbnail once she realized all that
facad that she does online all looking
all you know uh like you know she's all
cocky etc. Um and SP talking about this
woman and a pervert idea. Me seeing the
word cocky. I don't know what what's
going to go through her mind. I would
have been bl Okay. So, acting like that
and then she sends me a voice note and
says, "Oh, you're slandering me on your
thumbnail. You're making it look like I"
and you did say that. You said, "I I can
come. I'm like your wife. You literally
said that." And then she's telling me,
she's reminding me of my She's saying,
"Look, if you do that, then the sin is
on you." I'm thinking, "Bro, you
actually said that. What are you talking
about? Like, I made it up. You actually
said that." So, the thing is, she's
giving me this reminder. at the same
breath she's backbiting slandering my
wife. Okay, no problem. My wife when I
show she was laughing head off. Okay.
And then not only that you're backbiting
scholars you that you have no idea
about. So I don't understand. One minute
you're talking about don't backbite son
etc. And then next minute you're
slandering scholars to wash my bum. The
mushri in Mecca were already on
Ibrahim's dean. The prophet did not come
to give dava to atheists. These people
already knew about Allah. They believed
in Allah. They worshiped Allah. They
prayed. They made gul. They made taw. So
what was the problem? Why are they in
shik and why are they in in hell?
Because they were worshiping others than
Allah. And many people always think that
they were worshiping something
completely different. Like for example
the Hindus, they pray to cows. The
pagans they were praying to fire. These
people had other people like elders for
example and were claiming that these
people
bring them closer to Allah. Now think
about this. These people believed in
Allah but they also claimed that they
need other people
to be a servant to Allah. That reminds
me of something. I need hadith books to
be a servant to Allah. Without hadith
books, I cannot pray to Allah. Without
hadith books, I don't know how to wash
my bum. You must not put anyone between
you and Allah. And now look what you
claim. How can you not see this? It's
shocking to me. I'm just trying to ask.
Okay, let's let's see how dumb you are.
So, if that's the case, how I asked you
a simple question. How do you know how
to pray salah? Look, it it doesn't say
you cannot pray to Allah. It says it
shows you how to pray. Do you how many
times you pray a day? How do you knowul?
How do you know how to do? How do you
know what to do for the hajj ritual? How
do you know how to get married? Yes.
Okay.
>> How do you know? Okay. Let's go with
your ideology. If not only that we go to
the Quran only. Yes. That you find issue
with prophet's marriage Aisha at nine.
Okay. No problem. To your logic. To your
logic. This not our faith. We don't
believe in this. This to your logic. The
Quran says the period for a girl who's
not menrating. Girls not menrating can
be what the age of what? 1 2 3 4 5 6
what age? To your logic we don't believe
that. Yeah. Okay. To your religion. Yes.
If you reject you're a kafir. If you do
fully you are a kafir. So to your logic
then do you accept that Quran? Just
Okay. Let's go Quran only. Okay. So are
you okay with that? Are you comfortable?
Oh you want to reject the Quran now? Oh
I know. Let's try to make a
justification. You're just insecure.
Okay. You're talking about learning how
to wash your bum through the Quraysh.
Okay. So, subhan Allah. It's it's so a
you're using idols. The prophet wasallam
the said he was a walking talking Quran.
He manifested it. So, without hadith
literature, you have nothing. How do you
rely on it? How do you know the Quran
was revealed? How do you know? You're
going to talk the Sahabah. Oh, the
Sahabah. Okay, but the hadith came from
the same way. Like are you really that
like wall I'm genuinely bamboozled. My
main issue with you is this. I don't
care about your whole innuendos and this
that look you might have an obsession.
I'll be honest with you for you to keep
talking about being married to me, being
in love with me, sexual tension between
us, the stuff that you're saying I'll be
honest with you. It's very clear if
anyone has um wants anyone it's it looks
like from your side if I showed you this
anyone would watching this video will
say you didn't make those comments.
She's keep making those comments about
you married to you being in love with
you. um sexual tension between us. Okay.
So with all due respect, sister, I'm
just saying to you, I have no interest
on you at all. With all due respect, I'm
telling you, you're not second or third.
You forget wives concent. You're not
even there. W If you was the last, you
are I hate that. You know that look that
you have it. It repulses me. When I was
looking to get married, I have I'm
telling you me, I'm a natural I like a
woman of natural beauty. Alhamdulillah.
Okay. So please, with all due respect,
like please wall, there's no chance.
There's no chance. I'm just letting you
know. There's no chance. Okay. All
right. Alhamdulillah. Okay.
Alhamdulillah. Cuz my wife is in. Let me
be honest with you, boy. Let me tell
you. If you saw my wife, your jaw will
drop, please, sister. Yeah. All your
fake, you know, your lipstick, your
fake, they will drop. They will all fall
on the floor. Okay. They'll be like,
please. Yeah. Alhamdulillah. May Allah
protect her. A mean. Yeah. Okay. My
point is this here. Please put this
aside. Stop talking to me in a sexual
way. And all I just want to say is
inshallah, please answer these
questions. I dare you to answer these
questions. Yes. Okay. You can't have
your cake. Okay. We accept Quran hadith.
No, no, no. Manny came from the same
way. all these other rituals. How do you
do that? You're you're just an insecure
person. You can't deal with facts. And
because of that, you reject as you like.
Like Allah says in the Quran, you take
some verses, reject some verses. That's
what I'm going to say to our sister.
Yes. So next time, be careful. Don't
talk to married men in sexual ways, etc.
Please. Especially a man that has no
interest in you at all. Please. Okay.
Till next time, brothers and sisters.
Hope you guys enjoyed this video. Please
share it with our dear Jamila sister the
the the great scholar of our time.
Alhamdulillah. You know stick to your
plastic jabi tutorials please. You
better do that inshallah. Till next time
the sun is strong so it might melt all
those fakeness. Please use an umbrella.
Better get to.